un paso más hacia la eutanasia una
práctica a una y la infancia el consejo
consultivo nacional de ética ha
manifestado su apoyo a la idea de la
muerte asistida cuando los pacientes
están cerca del final de la vida un
dictamen que podría marcar un punto de
inflexión en este largo debate pero no
como
nuestra muerte nos pertenece y podemos
decidir las condiciones en las que
deseamos recibir asistencia para morir
es el papel del comité es ser una
brújula tanto para nuestros ciudadanos
como para los políticos para intentar
avanzar en un tema tan complejo
desde 2016 los médicos en francia pueden
mantenerse de a2 a los enfermos
terminales solo si su condición les está
causando gran sufrimiento y que es
probable que le conduzca a una muerte
rápida una vez que están en sueño
profundo se detienen los tratamientos
que mantienen el paciente vivo pero no
llega a permitir la muerte asistida una
ley insuficiente para las asociaciones
que defienden el derecho a morir con
dignidad más de nueve de cada diez
franceses desean este cambio es porque
desean tener el derecho a elegir las
leyes que están en vigor hoy en día se
hicieron para los que están alrededor de
la cama debería hacer cada uno el que
pueda tomar una decisión para su momento
final en la vecina bélgica la eutanasia
es legal desde hace 20 años steve esta
foto fue tomada a menos de tres horas
antes de la otan hacia katyn se mantuvo
al lado de su madre hasta el final
rodeada de familiares y más que el
recuerdo que tengo de mi madre es el de
una mujer que fue hacia su destino
pero en absoluto como una víctima l para
víctima el presidente manuel ma q ha
anunciado el lanzamiento de un debate
nacional sobre la posibilidad de
legalizar la muerte asistida con el
objetivo de modificar la ley para el
próximo año